[Musique]
alors ce soir je retrouve christine
kelly et am2 bien qu en très bien est ce
si le retour de notre ami gilles verdez
entre nous on me tourner voilà moi aussi
j'ai lu la lettre et revenir en forme
pour
[Rires]
il repose à l'instant et bim
on est là on de folie salut salut les
copains ça va ça va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hello
oh non quelles actions anglet et salut
toi tu es plutôt joli ballet
je
[Musique]
pas trop ce qu'il fait salut tout le
monde
bah écoutez je suis dans taxil avec un
taxi très très gentil comment vous
appeler monsieur robin bon avec david il
est restreint par sa vitalité
et je vais à sud radio les choux pour
parler de qui faisant série de mon livre
là qui sort jeudi et au conte et en août
on est en route on y va et donc je vous
retrouve sur france bleu natio pour
parler de l'optimisme pour parler du
livre pour parler de 2 qui fait de la
vie quoi a tout de suite les chéris
passer une bonne journée je vous
embrasse et je voulais juste vous dire à
tous ceux qui ont déjà reçu le livre qui
sont allés le chercher qui m'ont envoyé
des photos des messages des petits mots
voilà vous aimez les larmes aux yeux
fall 10 sél et sincère m'a émue les
larmes aux yeux ce matin donc merci
infiniment
je suis hyper touché je suis excité
voyez mine de rien moi j'aime bien ma
vie je suis lâche à montparnasse je
marche
il fait beau on est à paris est taxi qui
va m'écraser tout va bien nous embrasse
presse un nouveau salut les amis 4° 3°
s'abaisse sa bête
c'est un truc de fou bah je vous
embrasse
oui je suis encore dans le camion parce
que ça se fait pas du jour au lendemain
un congé sans solde
je vous embrasse à onexone vous les amis
rendez vous tout à l'heure tu es pmp
18h30 les dossiers chauds latu médian on
va parler de tout tout tout tout est
prêt tout est préparé
enfin par les autres parce que moi je
puisse en train de roupiller dans la
bagnole a donc tapé peau carrosse et
papeete chez en train de faire en somme
voilà sont en pleine forme lui des
félines loof également féline fiv
comment ça va je mange bien changé
gérer c'est la journée mondiale de
sourire
[Rires]
à
[Musique]
comment
mais quelle ciel bleu après avoir
profité de conseils en relooking de la
part de crise d'accor de la hier soir là
j'ai rendez vous avec philippe etchebest
pour les petits qu'aux de cuisine comme
ça jusqu'au plaisir
[Musique]